the collective anti-trans movement
um also wants many of us to believe that
gender affirming care is harmful but
there is extensive research from medical
governing bodies the American Medical
Association American Psychological
American Psychiatric association
American Academy of Pediatrics they have
endorsed gender affirming care even for
minors when you go through the correct
protocol now the right will say they're
chopping off the breasts of prepubescent
women
well they're not women and they don't
have breasts if they're prepubescent and
it's really not happening and when push
comes to shove they really struggle to
present any data that suggests that this
is an epidemic but it doesn't matter
it's about what can you trick people
into believing